Olá hoje Vamos bater um papo sério sobre
como você pode usar alimentos e
suplementos para se proteger de um
problema que ninguém quer enfrentar que
são os coágulos sanguíneos aqueles que
podem levar infarto trombose e até
derrame eu sei que só de pensar nisso já
dá um frio na espinha D arreios mas é
exatamente por isso que precisamos falar
sobre esse assunto recentemente eu fiz
dois vídeos importantes um falando sobre
sinais sintomas dos coágulos e outro
sobre alimentos que podem desencadear
esse problema então se você ainda não
assistiu dá uma conferida os links estão
aqui na descrição desse vídeo Primeiro
vamos entender de forma simples o que
acontece quando um coágulo se forma
dentro de um vaso sanguíneo seja veia ou
seja artéria esse coágulo chamado de
trombo pode obstruir o fluxo sanguíneo
causando problemas sérios se uma parte
desse trombo se soltar e viajar pelo
corpo ele se torna um êmbolo que pode
causar condições graves como trombose
venosa profunda ou TVP embolia pulmonar
ataque cardíaco ou derrame o acidente
vascular cerebral dependendo de onde ele
se aloja então um dos Segredos para
reduzir o risco de formação de coágulos
está na camada glicoproteica chamada
glicocálix que reveste o endotélio e faz
com que o sangue passe naturalmente
pelas artérias veias e capilares sem
coagular Pense nela como um veludo macio
e deslizante que cobre internamente
todas as artérias e veas do corpo das
maiores até os minúsculos vasos
sanguíneos essa camada atua como escudo
que impede que o sangue grude nas
paredes dos vasos evitando danos e
consequentemente a formação de coágulos
dentro dessa camada de glicocalix há um
ver veradeiro time de proteção nós temos
o óxido nítrico sintase que produz o
óxido nítrico uma molécula mágica paraa
saúde cardiovascular O óxido nítrico é o
anticoagulante mais potente do nosso
corpo Protegendo o endotélio e evitando
a formação de coágulos além disso O
glicocalix também tem Albumina uma
proteína produzida pelo fígado que ajuda
a manter e reparar essa camada protetora
é interessante saber que baixos níveis
de album
estão Associados a um risco maior de
doenças cardíacas quando a camada de
proteção do glicocálix é danificada as
células endoteliais que ficam por baixo
também podem ser afetadas o corpo ao
detectar esse dano responde formando um
coágulo sanguíneo na área para prevenir
o sangramento que é normal o problema
acontece quando temos áreas onde as
células da parede interna dos vasos no
glicocálix sendo aial são danificadas
constantemente então para reparar esse
dano o corpo envia células progenitoras
que estão sempre circulando o sangue
essas células cobrem o coágulo criam uma
nova camada mas esse processo de reparo
contínuo pode acabar engrossando a
parede da artéria com o tempo isso vai
crescendo e vai virar o que conhecemos
como placa
aterosclerótica nessas condições as
placas se acumulam
estreitando as artérias e se um grande
coágulo se formar em cima de uma placa
já existente no espaço que já está
Estreito pode acontecer então o ataque
cardíaco ou derrame esse coágulo também
pode se soltar e viajar pelo corpo
causando uma embolia pulmonar então o
que que nós podemos fazer devemos evitar
os fatores que danificam nossas artérias
proteger o nosso glicocálix e com isso
reduzir o risco de coágulos Cuidar dessa
camada protetora é um passo importante
para manter o nosso sistema
cardiovascular funcionando sempre bem
evitando assim problemas sérios do
Futuro a boa notícia é que embora a
camada de glicocálix possa ser
rapidamente destruída Ela também tem a
capacidade incrível de regeneração Em Um
Piscar de óleos então estudos mostram
que mesmo em áreas onde ela foi
completamente removida ela pode se
reparar totalmente em apenas alguns
segundos
incrível né então suplementos como
sulfato de condroitina e o msm o metil
sulfonil metano podem ajudar nesse
processo de recuperação Além disso
alimentos que aumenta a produção de
óxido nítrico são essenciais para manter
essa camada protetora saudável por
exemplo verduras Verde escuras como cve
agrião rúcula escarola repola e a celga
são ótimas escolhas por serem ricas em
Tratos e nitritos aminoácidos como l
citrulina e l arginina também contribuem
para aumentar os níveis de óxido nítrico
no nosso organismo e sabe aquela parte
branca da Melancia bem perto da casca
ela é especialmente eficaz em promover o
aumento dióxido nítrico Assim como as
sementes de abóbora e a prática de
atividade física moderada agora um
detalhe importante evite enxaguantes
bucais como é o caso do Listerine pois
esses enxaguantes eliminam as bactérias
Bogas da boca que são essenciais para
converter os nitratos dos alimentos em
nitritos que em contato com o ácido
estômago se converte em óxido nítrico
Então cuide das bactérias da sua boca
além de manter as paredes dos vasos
saudáveis outro aliado são as enzimas
fibrinolíticas naturais que ajudam a
quebrar os coágulos essas enzimas é o
caso da lumbrokinase natoquinase E
serrapeptase atuam como anticoagulantes
naturais dissolvendo na fibrina que é o
material de coagulação responsável pela
formação de coágulo sanguíneos Então as
enzimas
fibrinolíticas inibem a agregação
plaquetária e a formação de coágulos
sanguíneos de forma semelhante à
aspirina por exemplo a lumbrokinase que
é extraída de minhocas é cerca de 300
vezes mais potente que a serra peptase e
quase 30 vezes mais mais eficaz que a
natoquinase ela é um agente
antitrombótico altamente eficaz que
reduz a viscosidade do sangue e
agregação plaquetária enquanto também
degrada a fibrina pessoal é importante
usar essas enzimas de forma direcionada
e se tomá-las diariamente alternar entre
lumor kinase natoquinase e serra peptase
para evitar o desenvolvimento de
sensibilidade ou alergia se você
conseguir obter essa três formas e
lembre-se elas devem ser tomadas com
estômago vazio pelo menos uma hora antes
ou Du horas depois das efei que contém
proteína para garantir então a sua
eficácia e é muito importante fazer uso
Com acompanhamento médico OK agora que
você já sabe como os coágulos se formam
e quais são os alimentos e suplementos
que podem ajudar a evitar é hora de
falar dos principais fatores de risco
que você precisa ficar de olho e
corrigir para evitar esse problema sério
Primeiro vamos falar das infecções
virais que podem causar danos nas
paredes das artérias alguns vírus têm
preferência pelo endotélio e quando eles
invadem essa camada vão descamando e
destrói o glicocálix aumentando o risco
de coágulos a obesidade o excesso de
peso também é um fator importante pois
está ligado a problemas como pressão
alta e altos níveis de açúcar no sangue
que afeta o sistema cardiovascular o
tabagismo fumar é um grande vilão aqui
danifica diretamente as células que
revestem os nossos vasos sanguíneos
deixando o caminho livre paraa formação
de coágulos se você tem diabetes o risco
aumenta ainda mais porque a resistência
à insulina e também os altos níveis de
glicose de açúcar no sangue prejudicam
as artérias também metais pesados como
chumbo e alumínio são perigosos pois
danifica o Otélio aquela camada interna
dos vasos sanguíneos e a pressão alta
por si só já é um grande fator de risco
porque força o coração e as artérias a
trabalharem mais o que pode desgastar as
paredes arteriais bem na verdade eu
posso dizer que boa parte dos coagulos
sanguíneos ocorre durante ou logo após
uma hospitalização ou cirurgia isso
acontece porque ficar imóvel por longos
períodos de tempo como durante um
repouso prolongado na cama devido à
doença ou devido à recuperação de uma
cirurgia ou até mesmo em viagens longas
também aumenta o risco de
desenvolvimento desses coágulos então se
você já entendeu que ficar imóvel pode
aumentar o risco de coágulos Então já
deve ter entendido que a falta de
atividade física também é um fator de
risco importante então se você trabalha
sentado no computador não tem o hábito
de fazer atividade física de caminhar ou
até mesmo passa muito tempo deitado na
frente da TV tudo isso representa um
fator de risco grave pra formação de
coágulos Então se mexa pessoal não fique
parado Além disso durante a gravidez e
no período pós-parto o risco é maior
então se você tem um histórico familiar
como um pai mãe ou irmão que teve
coágulos isso também aumenta o risco se
você já teve um coágulo antes as chances
de ter outro aumentam na verdade cada 10
pessoas que tiveram um três delas terão
outro coágulo em até 10 anos ter tido
câncer recentemente ou ter câncer que se
repete recorrente também aumenta o risco
o uso de certos medicamentos
principalmente os anticoncepcionais
hormonais ou uma terapia de reposição
hormonal feita de forma errada
inadequada no momento errado ou pela via
de uso errada é um fator de risco risco
paraa formação de coágulos também Evite
o uso desnecessário de antiinflamatórios
não esteroidais é o caso desses
antiinflamatórios comuns de farmácia
iboprofeno
Naproxeno pois apesar de inibirem a
inflamação eles podem ativar o sistema
de coagulação sanguínea perceba que
estamos lidando com uma combinação de
vários fatores que podem influenciar
significativamente imagine uma pessoa
sedentária diabética que fuma ainda usa
algum remédio que é aento o risco quando
você tem essa combinação de fatores a
situação pode se tornar ainda muito mais
grave eu não posso deixar de falar sobre
a questão de alimentação uma alimentação
inflamatória contribui muito para
doenças crônicas alimentação rica em
carboidratos refinados alimentos
industrializados açúcar gorduras
inflamatórias como é o caso de óleos de
sementes que tem adição de gordura trans
a própria gordura trans frituras em
excesso alimento Ultra processados e
fast food tudo isso pode contribuir pra
formação de coágulos portanto evite óleo
de sementes como de soja canola e milho
que são ricos em ácido linoleico uma
gordura omega-6 que em excesso está
associado a várias doenças crônicas
incluindo pressão alta obesidade
diabetes e por último mas não menos
importante gerencie o seu estresse o
stresse crônico pode elevar o açúcar do
sangue também pode elevar a pressão
arterial promover a coagulação e
prejudicar o sistema de reparo do corpo
o cortisol desregulado o hormônio
estresse vai reduzir a produção de
células endoteliais o que pode levar a
dano nas artérias e consequentemente
pode levar à formação de coágulos então
Fique atento a esses fatores e tome as
medidas necessárias para manter as suas
artérias saudáveis e assim evitar
problemas no futuro Muito obrigado pela
sua atenção um grande abraço um beijo no
seu coração e você é feira